this is a newsie story you know there
are issues that you have to deal with
all I was doing a lot of groundwork
making contacts finding out where he
could fly where he couldn't fly there's
a lot of actually border issues there
you have issues like how do the
Jordanians and mom get their water that
was something Paulo had to suss off for
himself
follow the trucks that actually fill up
the cisterns on top of the buildings
because they ration water I think he
tries to put a little tension into his
images normally I don't go for the tilt
so much but with his work it seems to
work in his style
I think flows very well through these
images into the story